first of all what a style to shoot you  never want to wear off the floor like  you wear on the floor you don't want to  keep them tight like this right it's not  a good look when you want to wearing  with some jeans okay so you want to take  these out yeah you want to ease it on up  in today's world obviously we all know  that pants down slimmer you know when  you loosen the shoe strings you're able  to hide that gene if you want to  hydrogen in there or you want to give it  one cup we're not always just thinking  about performers we're also thinking  about hey if there's a guy to want to  ride his bike to school and it doesn't  play basketball he's in a chess club and  he wants to wear some LeBrons how can he  feel good about himself  I do that as well step number one knows  yeah yeah you got to loosen those in  Shushan is that baby unless you run it  from a dog that you might want to tie  Mona